the zany relationship between the Venom
symbiote and Eddie Brock in venom was
fun to watch but what everyone really
wants to see is the alien antihero take
on Peter Parker or at least that's what
Sony Pictures thinks and according to
one of the movies co-writers that very
meetup is in the cards right now in the
lead up to Venom's free Africa release
in October 2018 producers behind the
movie played coy about whether or not it
would be a part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe rumors were abundant that the
movie would feature a cameo from Tom
Hollands spider-man or even just Holland
as Peter Parker considering the
reputation that the MCU has for
consistent crowd-pleasing quality the
confusion was to venoms benefits
some people still think the movie is
part of the MCU which as we know now it
is not here's a breakdown of how it all
works when it comes to film rights most
of the Marvel Comics characters are
owned by Marvel Studios with the
exception of the characters related to
spider-man
according to Variety Sony holds the
rights to about 900 characters from the
spider-man corner of the Marvel Comics
universe so if Sony owned spider-man
then why is Peter Parker been hanging
out the Avengers so much
an Avenger after the disappointing
critical and commercial performance of
Sony's amazing spider-man 2 Sony and
Marvel worked out something of a shared
custody agreement for spider-man giving
Marvel creative rights to the character
for a stretch of five movies those
movies include Captain America Civil War
spider-man Home Coming Avengers infinity
war Avengers endgame and spider-man far
from home
as part of the agreement Sony apparently
gave up the right to produce their own
live-action spider-man movies but when
far from home comes out the deal will be
done for and Sony could then potentially
take spider-man back for themselves
now that venom has proved to be a
massive financial success earning more
than eight hundred and fifty million
dollars worldwide has since its release
it's increasingly looking like Sony will
be taking spider-man off Marvel's hands
in the designing venom special feature
included in the home release of the
venom movie co-writer Jeff Pinkner
teased a likely possibility of a venom
spider-man crossover going so far as to
assert that spider-man already exists in
Venom's universe the topic was brought
up as part of a discussion about fan
outrage over the movie's redesign of
venom
with the white spider emblem across the
characters chest being removed for the
live-action adaptation in the comics
venom gets a spider emblem thanks to the
symbiote first bonding with Peter Parker
but in this version of Venom's origin
the symbiote goes straight to Eddie
Brock with no spider-man connection as a
result of Venom's chest and the movie is
bare black in a movie where Spiderman
exists in the universe but does not
exist in our story it would make no
sense but as pigna puts it that aspect
of the movie Venom's design could change
if he in spider-man ever managed to
encounter each other a future movie down
the line that a symbiote and spider-man
might not share a moment and that
symbiote might end up with
splashed across his chest speaking to
screen rants before Venom's release
director Ruben Fleischer characterized
the spider-man and venom crossover as
being a sure thing eventually
he also said that the spider-man they
would want to use for the crossover
wouldn't be a new actor but instead the
current Peter Parker performer Tom
Holland the filmmaker said I think we
laid the groundwork in this film for a
pretty fun matchup in the future it
feels like that's inevitable and I know
that Tom Hollands excited about it and I
know that Tom Hardy is excited about it
so it's just a question of when and
where I guess that seems like the
natural evolution Sony has been laying
track for a spider-man crossover since
before venom was released reportedly
toning the movie down for a pg-13 rating
in order to make it easier for the two
characters stories to match up with each
other it remains to be seen how the
filmmakers would go about making a
crossover happen now that Venom's origin
story is so different in the comics the
symbiote was rejected by pizza before
latching on to Eddie who held his own
grudges against spider-man their mutual
hatred of spider-man made them a natural
nemesis and it's unclear how a crossover
would reverse engineer that relationship
there's also the fact that Tom Hardy's
Eddie is a grown man who lives in San
Francisco and Tom Hollands Peter is a
high school student who lives in New
York City also the venom in venom is
kind of a good guy why would he want to
go beat up a high school kid these
issues make it harder to imagine how a
team-up movie would actually work but if
the suits that Sony wants it bad enough
it's probably going to happen especially
since their take on venom made so much
money who cares about the story right
there's money to be made
you